thanks for joining us America we are
glad you are here open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well the news came out this week that
Google will no longer accept ads from
payday lenders a lot of people ask me on
Twitter what do you think about it if
you think it's awesome it's awesome it's
awesome well here's an interesting thing
about this I'm really a via Slee I don't
like payday lenders and obviously I
think it's a complete ripoff and that
they're feeding on poor people and it's
a scummy scummy scummy business and that
none of you should ever for any reason
step foot in a payday lender you're
going to get messed over now I've told
you that for 25 years here on the air
obviously payday lenders guess what the
Dave Ramsey show doesn't give will not
let any lenders advertise here we also
won't let people who sell gold advertise
here we also won't let people who sell
whole life life insurance advertised
here we also because we don't believe
it's good for you we don't let you
advertise on our show if you want to
lease a car to someone we don't like
credit card companies advertise on our
show so you know because we don't
believe it's good for folks we're a
private business or not a public utility
we're not a federal government we're not
a department of the government um and so
I get to choose who we allow to be on
our network Google is the same thing
there are private business the the
difference is obviously the Google's a
wee bit bigger than the Dave Ramsey show
just a little yeah I think you know I
mean they're ubiquitous it's just like
if you're if you can't find if you can't
if you can't be found on a Google search
you're like going to your bit your DEP
your business is going to be damaged
dramatically and so you know the word
came out Facebook is throttling
conservative articles and conservative
and Christian things and so forth this
week and Facebook has throttled us off
and on for years we've you know been
able to prove it it's not you know we're
not being paranoid but Facebook's a
private business they get to decide what
they want to have go through their
network
I don't get to decide that they get to
decide that Google gets to decide who
they want to advertise with who they
want to allow to advertise and that
doesn't mean you can't find a payday
lender on Google it means they're just
not going to take ads on its site
you know sponsored ads and Google words
and so forth that kind of a thing but
you can still find a payday lender on
Google and you know I took to my
knowledge Google doesn't take porn ads
either and basically payday lenders or
financial pornography that's what it is
so is you know is it you know it's
freedom of speech it's not freedom of
speech it's a private company
our culture has lost its ability to do
critical thought and so you know a lot
of your first reaction is if Google
won't let them do that but you know you
don't have a right to tell Google what
they can do they're an independent
company you don't have a right to tell
just cuz they're big didn't mean you get
to tell them what to do you don't get to
tell Walmart what to do I can't make
Walmart carry my books you know all Mart
refuses to do such-and-such well that's
Walmart's prerogative they're a private
business now they do carry my books by
the way we have a good relationship with
Walmart but we're actually kind of
Walmart fans around here but I thought
you know the point is is that you know
you can't make McDonald's have low
calorie meals they may choose to because
the marketplaces move that way and I
never thought I'd live to see the day
you could get a freakin salad that
McDonald's you know look gag you know
the worst possible thought is to eat a
salad at a place of it you know but it's
there man I mean you can now buy fruit
McDonald's oh my god
why because everybody's so gone nutso
over calories and it's almost as if some
of you people think that you have a
right to tell McDonald's what to do now
you tell them by not doing business with
them because you don't eat the crap that
they have and if that does that then
they'll change the crap that they serve
right and you
to do the same thing here if you don't
like the show you don't get to tell me
what I'm going to say it's called the
Dave Ramsey show ah means you know if
you if you were gonna you know the I've
you know you put your and insert your
name and get you a show and then you
know you can say what you want to say
but I get to say what I want to say here
that's you know how do you how do you
control that you don't listen anymore if
I have no listeners then I don't have
any power right I mean power to
influence anymore and so all of you
leave turn the dial that's what you do
and so if you don't but you don't get to
tell Google now I I actually applaud
Google for doing this I think there's
some other people ought to look up and
realize who they're advertising for and
what they're allowing their private
business to be used for that's not good
for people and but but I you know I'm
okay if they Lao into advertiser they
don't allow them to advertise its it's
irrelevant to me because I doubt that
Google's endorsement of the payday
lender industry or non endorsement
payday lender industry is really going
to [ __ ] them one way or the other
that you know they're not it's not their
market and so it but obviously I'm not a
fan of the payday lenders I just think
it's interesting that some of you go oh
I don't know meds freedom of speech we
didn't tell them they couldn't operate
nobody passed a law Google does not pass
laws they don't get to tell people where
they can be in business or not I just
get to tell them whether they can
advertise there or not you know like I
had a guy walk in here acting crazy in
the office one day I said you need to
leave he's like this was previous public
property it's not probably property you
doofus it says Ramsey on the front of it
I own it it's not public property and
now you gotta deal with a hillbilly
redneck get out of the building you're
acting crazy
you know and so because people are
stupid though you guys are some of you
have lost your critical thought you get
to tell private businesses how they act
no you don't you get to vote with your
wallet and your participation with that
business if you choose to never do
business with X Y or Z again because
they did something that you don't agree
with you don't like targets bathroom
policy or you don't like whatever that's
fine that's fine
but you know some of you think you've
got power that you don't have never
going to North Carolina again well I'll
be over there I like North Carolina you
know I like it I like Georgia too you
know I'll be there and be spending my
money there so it's okay you get to
decide that but you don't get this thing
where you're going to tell private
businesses how they operate and what
they can do and can't do because it's
freedom of speech is it's gotten out of
control
you know it's code for you know the only
the only speech that people are worried
about is speech that they like that's
the only kind of freedom of speech they
want people to have a speech that I
agree with and that's not what that's
not the way it works
tolerance is only things that I tolerate
is that's what it means out there today
so it's an interesting interesting
discussion this whole Google thing just
because it's revealed that some of you
actually feel like Google is so
ubiquitous that it's as if you have a
right to them everyone should have a
right to them under freedom of speech
just because they're big no nope
absolutely not they could decide
tomorrow to not let Dave Ramsey
advertise they could decide that and I
won't like it because we do a lot of
business with them I write a lot of
checks to Google every month big checks
we do a lot of Google search words a lot
of different things as part of our
social strategy here you know we it's a
fine organization we don't have any
trouble doing business with them all
that kind of stuff but they could just
decide tomorrow that they don't want us
as a customer they have that legal moral
and ethical right they could just go I
can do that and then you would have to
decide if you wanted to react to that or
not but I think most people will react
positively to them banning payday loan
advertisements at Google the decision is
the first time Google has announced a
global ban on ads for a broad category
of financial products according to the
article interesting to think about so
there you go but when the big dogs start
doing this stuff everybody pays
attention to what's happening on the
porch all of a sudden
there you go hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind